7,000 service jobs and very importantly
to me because you know what's happening
with manufacturing we're bringing it
back because we've made incredible trade
deals so manufacturing jobs are coming
back and we added three hundred and
fifty six thousand manufacturing jobs
credible credible numbers all records
African American workers made historic
gains the likes of which we've never had
before with four hundred and four
thousand new jobs in June that's a
record and that's the highest number
ever we had 700 thousand new jobs over
the last two months for African American
workers it's the highest ever and both
both months are the highest we shattered
last month's record that was a record
and we shattered it
Hispanic employment is up by 1.5 million
jobs great business men and women and
they're up 1.5 think of it million jobs
Hispanic eighty percent of small
businesses are now open new business
applications have doubled since late
March America's economy is coming back
much stronger than ever anticipated by
most people almost all people because
these numbers were even the most
optimistic people these numbers are
being doubled and tripled over what they
thought would be possible we're grateful
to be joined today by Secretary of
Commerce Wilbur Ross thank you very much
Wilbur thank you very much you're doing
a great job every company here today
embodies true American excellence you're
stunning craftsmanship I just witnessed
some of it it's incredible it's
treasured and prized all over the world
product you make is like none other and
your spirit for America and the
greatness of our country is unrivaled
with us a workers who make decorative
American flags from Virginia fly fishing
reels from Florida grills from Illinois
pies from North Carolina look very good
me coffee from Oklahoma ice cream from
Maryland and sunscreen and baseball bats
from Texas with unmatched skill and
devotion you make the goods and build
the products that proudly bear the
wonderful phrase made in the USA you're
seeing that more and more made in the
USA we're bringing our jobs back because
of trade deals we have great trade deals
and jobs are coming back and we have a
lot of great trade deals right now under
negotiation we got to get them done as
quickly as possible the small businesses
represented in this room continue a
great and noble American heritage your
entrepreneurs artisans creators
craftsmen who forge your own path made
your own products and provide
good-paying jobs for our citizens
credible jobs incredible people and they
truly are artisans and you're doing it
all with American hands American Heart
and American pride several of these
companies are entirely veteran owned and
operated especially as we approach
Independence Day I want to thank the
courageous men and women who have served
their country in uniform we vow to honor
your sacrifice by forever defending the
rights freedoms and principles you risk
your entire life to defend following the
arrival of the plague from China that's
what it is it's a plague and it should
have never happened
China should and never let that happen
but China did allow it to happen we just
signed a brand-new trade deal and the
ink wasn't even dry when this came over
but we raced into action to save our
nation's small businesses we passed over
three trillion and historic relief
measures three trillion dollars think of
that including over 670 billion dollars
for the Paycheck protection program a
tremendous success as you can see by the
numbers to keep small business workers
on the payroll
I signed a bill provide
federally-funded paid sick leave and
paid family leave for American workers
things that have never been done we're
allowing businesses to defer paying
their income tax and we expanded tax
refunds very substantially thanks to our
efforts and the incredible resilience of
our nation's small businesses and I
really think we can add the foundation
that we built we built the greatest
economy ever built and that foundation
was so strong that instead of coming
weekly back or going in the other
direction because this is coming back
and we haven't totally succeeded yet we
will soon but we haven't killed all of
the virus yet and yet you look at these
numbers and that's based on a very
strong foundation that we built a
foundation like no other a foundation
that had we not been attacked by this
virus is horrible virus we were doing
things and had things planned that
nobody else had ever even thought of
paying off debt building numbers the
likes of which nobody's saying and yet
next year we'll be in a position where I
believe in a certain respect I think
we'll even be stronger than we would
have been because of what we're doing
but only that strong foundation allowed
us to be up here today talking about
these record-setting job numbers and
other numbers that were producing
because America's economy is now roaring
back to life like nobody's ever seen
before nobody's ever seen numbers like
this in May retail sales surged by
nearly 18% that's a record we recently
saw the best 50-day increase in the
history of the stock market so we had 50
days go back a couple of weeks we had 50
days the likes of which we've never had
in the history of the stock market which
to me means jobs and it's lifting up
401ks and retirement savings for
American workers we're doing numbers
like nobody has ever seen before take a
look at 401ks in a pandemic we're almost
even
with where we were before the pandemic
started and nobody would have said that
was possible nobody at all
we built the greatest economy in the
history of the world and we are now
doing it again and I think we'll do even
better the second time that we did the
first time unless somebody comes along
and says let's raise taxes on everybody
and they're raising taxes not only on
corporations they'll just go to another
country and they'll do just fine but
they're raising taxes on people and
middle-income people and they're losing
jobs so you can't allow that to happen
that will be all of this incredible job
that we've done will go down like that
it will be a terrible terrible sight it
might even be a 1929 situation so you
have a chance to have the greatest
numbers in history you're almost there
we're almost back to where we were from
the standpoint of the stock market think
of that but you'll have a crash like
you've never seen before you put the
wrong person in office you'll see things
that you would not have believed or
possible they want to raise taxes they
want to raise regulations you know a big
part of what we've done is by cutting
regulation we've cut regulation more
than any president in the history of our
country whether they're there for four
years eight years or in one case more
than that nobody even came close and
we're doing much more we have regulation
but it's proper regulation not
strangulation
we're also tapping into the Talon genius
and the drive of our people to kill the
virus
we're speeding the delivery of new
treatments including antiviral steroids
convalescent plasma and other therapies
we have therapeutics that are really
really looking good and this includes
two drugs that have proven effective
remedy severe and dexamethasone which is
having a tremendous trial and we'll see
how that all happens but we have three
vaccine candidates we've had many more
but three are really really looking good
and I think
gonna have an answer to that verse and
three vaccine candidates are now in
trial with three more to start very
shortly these are all great companies
they've had tremendous success with
other problems in the past and we're
accelerating production through
operation warp speed plus we have our
military ready so that should we get
whether it's therapeutic or vaccine our
military is ready logistically ready
these are the best in the world to get
it out to everybody as soon as we have
it and we think we're gonna have it soon
as we prepare to celebrate the fourth of
July let us renew our devotion to this
nation to its citizens and the eternal
values that define our past and shape
our future I'm going to Mount Rushmore
on July 3rd we're gonna have a
tremendous evening it's going to be a
fireworks display like few people have
seen it's going to be very exciting it's
going to be beautiful they've been
wanting to do that for years fireworks
they used to do it many years ago and
for some reason they were unable or
unallowable I third and then we're
coming back here celebrating the 4th of
July in Washington DC and I want to also
thank all of law enforcement the job
you've done is incredible we signed a
bill you play with our monuments or our
statues you go to jail for 10 years it's
amazing how it all stops so fast stop so
fast we let the local authorities handle
it as long as possible but ultimately we
said let's step in and we stepped in and
it stopped ten years in jail if they
knew what they were doing so we're very
proud of law enforcement we want to
thank law enforcement a really great job
military's been incredible our National
Guard has been just incredible all over
I'm glad to see in Seattle they took
care of the problem because as they know
we were going in to take we were ready
to go in and they knew that too and they
went in and they did what they had to do
we're a nation committed to equal and
abundant opportunity for citizens of
every race color religion and
Creed the American Dream is the sacred
birthright of every American child
that's what we have is we have the
American Dream and nobody's gonna
shatter the American dream not the
anarchists not the agitators not the
fools not the looters they're not gonna
have any impact on the national dream
the national dream like no other that's
why we're here today to ensure that
every citizen can achieve their dream
achieve their destiny and realize their
full and extraordinary potential that is
how we will renew rebuild and restore
America we've done an incredible job in
a three and a half year period a job
like nobody thought would be possible to
be done and we're doing it again and
we're doing it I believe bigger and
better and stronger than ever before
you're going to see that next year and
unless it's tampered with we're gonna
have a year next year like no other
it'll be a phenomenal year successful
year and we'll have our best job numbers
ever next year we'll come back stronger
and more prosperous than ever before and
next year will be I think it'll be one
of the from an economic standpoint the
greatest or one of the greatest economic
years we've ever had so I just want to
thank everybody for being here I want to
thank all of these incredible artisans
and businesspeople for showcasing your
amazing products and I just want to
leave you by saying very important words
god bless america
thank you all very much thank you
[Applause]